why does it says
that was for rain
Kourtney Kardashian's eight-year-old son
rain steals the spotlight at her wedding
to Travis Barker I mean it's a beautiful
thing on Thursday fans got an intimate
look inside the couple's nuptials on
their Hulu special till death do us part
Courtney and Travis can you believe we
got married three times yeah three was
the magic number for the reality star
and the Blink 182 drummer I guess what
happens in Vegas doesn't always stay in
Vegas first an unofficial ceremony in
Las Vegas after the Grammys in April
2022. you did a practice run on the
wedding congratulations thank you I got
a call to the celebrity wanted to get
married they didn't tell me what it was
they just said a celebrity and we need
helps we knew that Elvis had to marry us
I didn't even remember Elvis like saying
to me walking down the aisle I just
didn't remember I didn't remember I had
a bouquet and did the bouquet toss
shortly after all that in May the two
made it official with an intimate
courthouse wedding in Santa Barbara
before flying overseas and tying the
knot in front of their closest friends
and family in Portofino Italy I'm just
like living life quartz kiddos Mason
Penelope and Rain whom she shares with
her ex Scott Disick were all there so
were Travis's kids Landon and Alabama
whom he shares with his ex Shayna
Moakler as well as shayna's daughter
Atiana but it was rain who brought the
entertainment okay
[Music]
like that moment making faces during the
sweet family portrait which Court's
Sister Chloe promptly shut down I'm
gonna figure it all out I promise you
we're all all Gonna Learn during the
ceremony which was held at the estate of
designers Dominico Dolce and Stefano
Gabbana rain who served as the ring
bearer walked all over his mama's Veil
brain if you could bring me the Rings
thank you and understandably he had a
hard time pronouncing Dolce Gabbana why
does it says
and when everyone was letting loose at
the reception rain dared his mom to say
one specific four-letter word loud and
clear into the mic
[Applause]
that was for rain and he was literally
all of us during Travis's speech we were
all here because I fell in love with my
best friend wow
of course rain's been known to bring the
LOLs who could forget when he joined his
mom on Ellen in 2019.
what's your name rain yeah
well hopefully we'll see more of Court's
youngest kiddo on season three of the
Kardashians streaming on Hulu May 25th I
wish I could tell you this is going to
be a mild relaxing Serene season
it's not
foreign